What if your wallet was a Google Wallet?
It would start with your cards: credit and debit.
Visa, MasterCard, American Express and Discover,...
...all stored securely in the cloud.
All your cards, all together, in a virtual wallet that goes anywhere.
Use it on your phone and tap to pay for a double shot macchiato at your favorite cafe.
Or a taxi ride to the club.
Or gummy bears at the movie theater.
And when you go online, your wallet goes with you.
So it's easier than ever to order everything you need for your next vacation.
And that new song from your favorite band is just a single click away.
Whether you're shopping in-store or online,...
...Google Wallet keeps all your payment info safe and secure.
It's everything you love all in one wallet.